[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invitan a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas comenzamos en francia
donde para hacer frente al aumento del
consumo de drogas como el crack las
autoridades han instalado los llamados
centros de inyección seguros aunque son
experimentales el gobierno planea
ampliar esta iniciativa que ha
despertado molestias en muchos vecinos
que ven peligros en la llegada de estos
sitios destinados al consumo controlado
de estupefacientes a sus barrios pauline
no hago casanova y eloise mellon fueron
a visitar uno de estos polémicos lugares
jeringas cucharas filtros torniquetes en
esta sala adaptada en parís los adictos
pueden drogarse con menos riesgos
gracias a un material esterilizado eso
le pasa a la gente de la calle es mejor
que la gente consuma de un espacio
seguro todos acá dicen cuando empiezan a
venir que consumen menos porque se
sienten más tranquilos
cada día la sala acoge más de 300
usuarios canela ha acudido regularmente
desde la apertura hay menos riesgos si
tienes una sobredosis están acá siempre
es útil incluso cuando llevas años
usando drogas sigue cometiendo errores
en 2016 el barrio se había movilizado
contra el establecimiento del centro de
inyección seguro cinco años más tarde
ciertos vecinos siguen viendo su cierre
esto lleva a peleas agresiones
inseguridad por no hablar de las
jeringas utilizadas que se encuentran en
el suelo cerca de los niños para mí
estas estructuras tienen que quedarse
lejos de las viviendas de las escuelas
de los jardines infantiles frente a las
agrupaciones de adictos en parís dos
diputados han encontrado usuarios y
vecinos y han visitado la sala de
consumo
hemos visto que es un dispositivo eficaz
en dos condiciones por un lado que estas
personas estén integradas a una atención
médica y social más completa y con el
objetivo de frenar el consumo y por otro
lado que la implantación de esta sala
sea concertada con las autoridades
sanitarias las fuerzas del orden pero
también los vecinos sólo auxilio arriba
el gobierno francés acaba de anunciar la
creación de dos salas cada año una
decisión que podría generar controversia
y continuamos en francia porque avanza
el juicio por los atentados terroristas
del 13 de noviembre de 2015 que dejaron
130 muertos y centenares de heridos han
pasado casi 6 años desde que llega
distas lanzaron ataques en cercanías del
sat de fonz dispararon contra bares de
la capital y mataron a decenas en el
bataclán en este proceso que durará
varios meses los sobrevivientes y las
familias de las víctimas de la sala de
conciertos ya han comenzado a ofrecer
sus testimonios de lo que fue aquella
horrible noche que los ha dejado llenos
de traumatismos que permanecen vivos y
que ha cambiado sus vidas para siempre
testificar para que nadie olvide desde
hace varios meses
dayton prepara su intervención en una
hoja de papel escribe una serie de
preguntas que hago yo con todo esto y
que haré después quiere expresar todas
las preguntas que lleva dentro pero
también contar aquella noche de horror
en el bataclán
soy de placer millones
y moverse rodeado de cuerpos sin vida
pasar horas cubierto de sangre ajena
solo quiero poder hablar de estos
pensamientos que me acompañan día y
noche desde hace casi seis años
ni gay tony los demás testigos podrán
dirigirse directamente a los acusados en
el tribunal pero su relato está por
supuesto destinado a ellos
me gustaría que admitirán que han sumido
a cientos miles de vidas en la
desolación y la desesperación
quizá tengo la esperanza secreta de
devolverles la humanidad ua duraban
discutidísimo junto a gay ton 360 parte
civiles declararán ante el tribunal a
pocos metros de los acusados
más de 13.000 migrantes haitianos buscan
ser regularizados en mexico muchos
huyeron de su país hace varios años
escapando de la pobreza algunos llegaron
desde sudamérica y otros simplemente han
abandonado su ideal de cruzar hacia eeuu
ver en méxico un país que puede
ofrecerles suficientes oportunidades
laborales sin embargo en la capital
viven en condiciones difíciles ya que
los albergues se mantienen llenos y no
existe infraestructura suficiente para
recibirlos el siguiente es un reportaje
de nuestros corresponsales en la capital
mexicana lo construiría y matthew como
ante la comisión de asistencia a los
refugiados decenas de haitianos se
aferran cada mañana a la esperanza de
ser regularizados como la mayoría de
ellos ya pasó varios años en sudamérica
pero su objetivo era llegar a méxico
para estar más cerca de su país natal
con esa meta cruzó nueve países en
pésimas condiciones días atrás la
guardia nacional lo agredió
violentamente a él ya su esposa pese a
eso quiere establecerse aquí
no tengo la idea de irme a eeuu quiero
quedarme aquí para trabajar en méxico
veo que hay trabajo solo espero tener
los documentos porque si no podemos
vivir sin papeles como los documentos
que hicieron de pub y visita para pie en
las últimas semanas a cientos de
inmigrantes haitianos han llegado a la
ciudad de mexico y viven en condiciones
precarias
romeu sound news encontró lugar en este
refugio dejó haití hace casi cuatro años
y su vida sufrir la violencia de la
crisis política en haití es una
violencia física y moral
hay pocos refugios en la ciudad de
méxico y todos carecen de espacio para
hacer frente al flujo de migrantes
haitianos en los últimos días los
voluntarios instalaron camas
improvisadas hasta en el techo con
hombres solos ahorita las personas que
estaban en familia lo hemos intentado
moverlas en otro albergue regularmente
tenemos capacidad para 25 incluso hasta
30 quizás en un día por ejemplo
recibimos 30 personas más las 20 que ya
estaban y al siguiente día estaba en
esas mismas 30 más otras 20 que llegaron
pese a la falta de infraestructura y a
la urgencia de la crisis migratoria el
gobierno de la capital mexicana no tiene
la intención de abrir centros de acogida
adicionales
las iniciativas de emprendimiento se han
multiplicado como consecuencia de una
pandemia que se llevó por delante
millones de empleos en todo el mundo y
en la capital española a mediados de
septiembre se celebró la feria de
emprendimiento y colombianidad 2021
nuestra corresponsal en esa ciudad laura
campo fue el encuentro de estas personas
que buscan hacer salir adelante sus
pequeños negocios en el país que nos
acoge y algunos han logrado cosechar
grandes éxitos
[Música]
en medio del distrito financiero de
madrid una representación del carnaval
de barranquilla un símbolo para el
lanzamiento de la feria de emprendedores
colombianos en españa
estas son 750 estas a 250 mesas muchos
como carolina vienen para presentar su
nuevo negocio quiero emprender porque es
lo que más me apasiona emprender mi
propia idea y crear mi propia marca se
encuentra con el ver que ha creado un
centro de emprendimiento para
colombianos les acompaña en cuestiones
administrativas y financieras nos
enfocamos directamente ayudarle a crear
a usted su microempresa para que empiece
a comercializar pues me parece
maravilloso porque en este corto tiempo
que yo llevo intentando emprender me he
sentido profundamente sola
los colombianos emprenden cada vez más
un fenómeno que se ha acelerado con la
pandemia como lo ha notado el consulado
de colombia hay muchos que la han pasado
mal que tienen dificultades económicas
porque perdieron sus empleos
están emprendiendo según el ministerio
de inclusión de españa 10 mil
colombianos trabajan por su propia
cuenta en el país dos veces más que hace
cinco años la gran mayoría son
microempresas pero el cirujano plástico
camilo esquivel consiguió crear una
compañía de clínicas estéticas de las
más importantes
estos son tratamientos que ayudan
también a prevenir el envejecimiento
hace 12 años comencé solo con un
empleado era yo atendiendo como médico y
era una chica que saben en recepción
ahora mismo la empresa tiene 100
empleados y tenemos clínicas en 6
ciudades
esta tendencia al emprendimiento se nota
también con otros latinos sobre todo
venezolanos y argentinos
el pasado 11 de octubre si la ciudad más
grande y poblada de australia puso fin a
más de 100 días de restricciones
impuestas para frenar los rebrotes de
kobe 19 y ahora el siguiente reto de las
autoridades es la reapertura de las
fronteras internacionales que podrían
llegar a principios de noviembre las
estrictas políticas fronterizas durante
un año y medio han hecho que cientos de
miles de australianos no hayan podido
regresar a casa y muchos aún vean esa
posibilidad como algo poco probable el
siguiente es un reportaje de cahuish
gatland julian sobre y clovis casas
bueno
durante más de un año el único contacto
que willy biliar ha tenido con su esposa
e hijos es a través de esta pantalla
vive a 180 km de parís mientras que su
esposa anna y sus tres hijos están en
brisbane en la costa este de australia
las políticas fronterizas de kobe 19 del
país han hecho que viajar sea
prácticamente imposible
no tienes cumpleaños no tienes
aniversarios de boda no tienes navidad
no tienes nada de nada no tomas café con
esa persona todas las mañanas tomábamos
café con los niños con mi esposa antes
de ir a trabajar no tienes ese café de
la mañana está para la chica efectiva
cuando ocurrió la pandemia willy estaba
de licencia sabática en el estado de
queensland con su familia en septiembre
de 2020 los dejo para volver a su
trabajo en francia pensando que se
reuniría en esa navidad en cambio las
medidas de 40 en los hoteles se
mantuvieron y los límites de las
llegadas internacionales se volvieron
aún más estrictos lo que elevó las
tarifas aéreas ahora el gobierno federal
quiere que las fronteras se vuelvan a
abrir a los ciudadanos una vez que el
80% de los australianos estén vacunados
pero algunos estados como queensland
dicen que eso no necesariamente sucederá
realmente no nos permitimos tener
esperanzas es difícil porque tenemos
miedo de ser decepcionados una abogada
viviendo en parís clair campbell también
temía la decepción todo eso cambió la
semana pasada cuando su estado natal de
nueva gales del sur dijo que reabriría a
la ciudad danos vacunados el próximo mes
y reemplazaría el costoso aislamiento
del hotel con cuarentena domiciliaria
ahora ha reservado un vuelo para pasar
la navidad con su familia es una
situación extraña porque me mudé aquí
con la expectativa de regresar uno o dos
veces al año así que mudarme aquí y no
poder regresar por casi dos años ha sido
una experiencia extraña así que estoy
definitivamente aliviada de poder ir a
casa de visita desde el inicio de la
pandemia los vuelos de repatriación del
gobierno han ayudado a unos 27.000
australianos a regresar a casa
aproximadamente
45 mil personas todavía están en lista
de espera
gracias por seguir esta nueva emisión de
corresponsales siga con más en france 24
y france 24 puntocom